chicken eating the rock seems to lack
the basic intelligence required pretty
much everything Moana too definitely has
to happen soon right there are just so
many mysteries and unanswered questions
we want to see solved we can't imagine
Disney not making a sequel to this
fantastic story but what would that
movie ultimately look like Moana
introduced us to a whole new world that
we fell in love with almost instantly
and want to see more of but for a sequel
to work we need answers to some of our
burning questions curious to see which
dangling plot threads Moana too needs to
address just keep watching the video to
find out Moana ended with our heroine
setting off into parts unknown with a
promise to discover brand new islands
and the sequel would have to answer the
big question of what's out there any
story Moana to hotel has to see Moana
and her tribe exploring new islands and
encountering new people or else the
ending of the first movie wouldn't be as
effective the world Moana was able to
create in such a short amount of time
was really interesting and we hope a
sequel continues to expand and build in
exciting new directions Congrats Moana
you became the new chief at the end of
the first movie but as we all know being
in charge is never easy anyway the first
movie showed us just how strong and
capable Moana was on her own but what
happens now that she's in charge of her
people's well-being we imagine Moana is
a kind and fair leader but her had
strong tendencies might clash with the
rest of her tribes tradition and culture
but we're not too worried her people
were willing to adapt to new changes in
the first movie so we would bet that
they would listen to what Moana has to
say
we were voyagers Moana was so successful
thanks to the beautiful animation and
fun story but a lot of props have to be
given to the cast for crafting
characters with such wonderful
personalities any sequel with these
characters needs to bring back the
original cast or it just wouldn't be the
same
could you imagine anyone else besides
Ally eek ravallo as Moana or Dwayne
Johnson as Maui
no without those two then any sequel
just wouldn't work plus alan tudyk did
career best work as hey hey so he would
definitely need to come back - right
speaking of Dwayne Johnson his character
Maui was a highlight from the first film
admit it
you're humming you're welcome right now
aren't you but his character arc seems
to have wrapped up perfectly after he
helped her to return the heart of taffy
T so what will the shape-changing
demigod do now we mean he has been
trapped on an island for like a thousand
years doing nothing but counting his
days and carving statues of himself do
you think he'll be surprised with how
much the world has changed now that he's
free to roam around what new adventures
could he get into we need to know the
early scenes of the first film showed us
just how curious Moana was ever since
she was younger as a child she was an
adventurous cutie pie who wasn't afraid
to explore the ocean but something funny
happened the ocean seemed to choose
Moana from a young age to be the one to
return the heart but why is that is it
because the ocean saw the person Moana
would become or could there be a deeper
more mystical reason that could be
explored in the sequel her connection
with the water was a vital part of the
first movie and we hope they're wet
connection gets more focused in the next
movie
when Moana is Grandma passed away it was
a devastating blow to Moana but just
because her body was gone doesn't mean
her spirit was gone - we know that
mallanna's grandma got to become the
spiritual stingray she always wanted to
be and arrived to give Moana key advice
near the end of the film but could we
see her grandmother return again as
Moana spirit guide in the sequel we hope
so
it would serve as a nice reminder of how
important the character is overall to
Mona's personal growth don't you think
we were all shocked when the flaming hot
tikka was revealed to just be taffy tea
without her heart but it left a movie
without a true central villain for ammo
on and Maui to face because the sequel
would probably not want to follow the
same story beats as the first movie we
expect there to be a big bad
will cause trouble for Moana and Maui as
they continue on their adventure could
it be another demigod like Maui or maybe
it's a hostile group of Islanders who
don't want mo Ana's outside influence
either way we're super excited
[Music]
even though he said he was a drab little
crab once we all saw just how large and
shiny Tama Toa grew to be last we saw
him he was tricked by Moana because his
eyesight was a little poor and our
heroes escaped with Maui's hook but is
the extravagant monster now out for
revenge we'd like to see the character
returned in the sequel just this time
we'd advised he gets a pair of glasses
you know just so he doesn't mix up
important stone hearts with marine
barnacles again one concept that was
introduced in Moana that wasn't explored
to its full potential with lava tide the
realm of monsters that sounds like a
pretty big deal the next movie could
easily make its whole plot revolve
around this maybe the monsters that were
previously dormant have now woken up
thanks to Maui MO Ana's meddling and
they threatened to overtake our world
overall it's just a place we want to
know more about a big part of Mo Ana's
narrative was discovering secrets about
the past do you really think our
ancestors stayed within the reef after
living her life on her Island without
ever leaving Moana was shocked to
discover that her people were descended
from voyagers who'd go out and explore
new exciting places rather than stay put
we got brief snippets of her ancestors
throughout Moana but a sequel should
totally dive into mo Ana's people
history even more so we think flashbacks
could work well we're perhaps Moana has
to contact the spirits of our ancestors
for answers to extremely difficult
questions either way we're down for it
after we met Maui on his secluded island
we all got a pretty clear picture of
what type of demigod he was although a
great warrior Maui was extremely
arrogant and cocky about his abilities
he thought he was the greatest thing on
the face of the earth but how did he get
that way was Maui always as much in love
with himself or did he slow
get that way over time that's why a
mallanna sequel should dig into Maui's
background to find out what events made
him into the person we know today
there's an unspoken rule in most Disney
films whoever the protagonist is you can
bet they're going to have a cute animal
sidekick the Moana totally surprised us
by introducing puah the adorable pig who
looked to be best friends with Moana but
then left him on the island when she set
sail taking hay with her instead not
that we don't love hey hey but we're
really hoping puah gets to set sail with
Moana on her next adventure the pig
deserves the spotlight the heart of
Kapiti was the key to everything in
Moana it was the object our heroes had
to return to stop darkness from
spreading everywhere and to save
mallanna's Island from rotting away but
we never got a full explanation of the
hearts full powers why does removing it
caused such destruction across the land
and why does it take so long for the
effects to truly be felt now he stole
the heart years and years ago but Moana
Thailand wasn't really affected until
much later
a sequel might move on from taffy T and
her heart but the mystical properties of
that special stone is still something we
want more information on one of the
coolest things about Maui are his
tattoos each to pick some cool event in
Maui's life but they also hold great
significance to him he told us how he
got a few of them but he has so many all
over his body that were left unexplained
a sequel to Moana should get into more
of Maui's history and his previous
adventures plus we're so eager to learn
more about his little friend Maui has
tattooed on himself that acts as his
conscience and his guide he's a
character that deserves more fleshing
out even though it never spoke the ocean
was a major character in the first movie
it helped guide Moana wherever she
needed to go and was watching over her
from a very young age but the ocean is
just one element if the ocean has a mind
of its own does that mean that there are
other elemental spirits that have just
as much personality could a sequel see
air earth or fire act in the same way
that the ocean does and would it be as
kind and helpful as the ocean or would
it act differently to
Yanis we're not sure how safe following
a fire spirit would be we learned in
moaña that Maui was born to human
parents but they threw him out to sea as
an infant because they didn't want him
he was saved by the gods and was raised
to become the mighty warrior we now know
him as but why did his parents cast him
aside in the first place a great
plotline for Maui and Moana too could
see him learning more about his human
past and his ancestors sure it's been
centuries but we believe the writers
could come up with a clever way to have
Maui explore more about where he came
from Moana and her father chief tui
butted heads a lot in the first movie
while Moana wanted to go out and explore
the world chief tui was adamant about
staying put and never leaving it
forstman wanted to venture off on her
own now that her people are full on
voyageurs i was her dad's way of
thinking change is he still hesitant
about the level of exploring their
people do or as he completely changed
his mind we can't wait to see more
interactions between Moana and her
father now that the two of them are
entering a completely new future
together is it just us or did the
coconut pirates known as the Camorra
deserve more screentime kind of cute
these feisty little coconut demons
appeared in the middle of the 1st Moana
movie in their pirate ship to steal the
heart away from our heroes of course
Moana and Maui were triumphant but it
still made us super curious about these
evil pirates where do they come from do
any of them talk like humans what do
they do in their spare time when they're
not pirating the high seas any Moana
sequel needs to include these guys again
just so we could find out more about
them we know that before he was banished
now he loved humans and wanted to give
them all sorts of lavish gifts and new
things but as humans became accustomed
to his gifts now he felt he had to go
bigger which led him to stealing the
heart of two fede in the first place he
knew that the heart had the ability to
create life but we're curious about what
now he expected humans to do with such a
gift it's
a minor thing but answering that
question in the sequel would give us
valuable insight in Maui's character now
here's a crazy theory is hey actually a
genius the first movie showed the
bug-eyed chicken as a creature with less
than stellar intelligence and yet the
chicken always managed to do the right
thing when the time called for it was it
all just luck or is there more to Hays
than meets the eye how crazy would it be
for Moana to to reveal hey hey is
actually a smart spirit just hiding in
the body of a dumb chicken okay we're
not sure if this one's true or not but
you can trust we'll be keeping a close
eye on hey hey during the sequel what do
you guys think should happen in Moana to
let us know in the comments your wildest
Moana two theories and be sure to hit
that subscribe button for more awesome
content from the things thanks for
watching